Carole Kirschner: If you have an idea that
could be on the show, that’s not quite good
enough.
It should be something that fits in, that
captures the voice and tone of the show, but
goes a little beyond what they do.
My favorite, favorite spec concept was for
Cheers [TV series that ran from 1982 to 1993]
which most of your viewers will not know anything
about.
Film Courage: I loved it!
Carole Kirschner: I loved it.
So in real life The Pope came to Boston where
that show is set.
And The Guy in White went down the main street
in his Pope-mobile and in this spec The Pope
goes to Cheers [the bar in the tv show] because
he has to use the bathroom.
So The Pope goes into the bathroom, leaves,
and people are just stunned that The Pope
came and used their bathroom and then somebody
steals the toilet.
The thing about it is, it’s a funny concept
and it was a way to show each of the main
characters, what their views on religion and
spirituality were.
So any time you can pick a concept where you
reveal more about the characters, the better.
Film Courage: Okay, so if you know let’s
suppose Silicon Valley is the show that you
love.
And you know these characters would definitely
do this and I can totally see this working,
that’s almost a negative?
Carole Kirschner: No, no, it’s not a negative.
That’s the starting point, is that this
is accurate, this is something that fits into
this world.
And then you try something that pushes it
a little bit.
Not aliens are landing.
That’s a really bad idea.
You want to stay with the reality of the world,
but just go deeper.
Find something deeper about the character.
And I once said on a podcast start your script
with affairs, passing on or greed.
They always work.
Grab people’s attention with one of those
things.